WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Good afternoon,
since it's now an
afternoon session.
That wasn't the
original plan, but we're
glad to have you there.
Thank you for coming.
I'm William Vambenepe.
I'm a product manager
and I lead the PM team
for big data services on
Google Cloud Platform.
And with me today is Reza.
REZA ROKNI: Reza Rokni.
I'm part of the Global
Solution Architect team
and I work directly with our
customers, product management,
and engineering.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
One way to start
thinking about the
value of big data
is just by an example of what
Google did with Street View.
You're pretty familiar
with the feature.
A while ago, Google started
to send cars all over cities,
and then more than
cities, countryside,
cars, eventually,
to really take pictures of
many, many parts of the world.
And originally, this was really
just a feature of Google Maps.
The only reason to do that
was that it would be nice,
when people look at a
destination on Google Maps,
to show them what
the place looks
like that they're looking at.
And so that was a great feature.
We needed pictures.
Take the pictures and
show that on the map.
What's very interesting
is that, over time,
as technology improved and
as the cost of technology,
especially at scale,
went way lower,
a lot more data was
accessible from those images.
And so today, all those
images going back over time
to many, many years, in addition
to being nice to look at,
can be used to extract
data from them.
Such as, in this case, the
street number, the signs,
what the display,
what's in the window.
What product is advertised,
at that point of time,
in the window?
And really, a lot
more information
that suddenly gives a lot
more perspective on what's
happening in the world.
The reason why I like
this example is not
that-- this is not talk
about Vision API or something
focused on images.
It really illustrates
the fact that there
is, very often, a lot
more value in the data
than the original purpose for
which the data was collected.
And in due time, as the
technology improves,
as the costs go down, as it
becomes easier and easier
for everyone to process data,
that data gets uncovered
and its value realized.
And the fact that you're
here today, that really
puts you in the same
position as the Maps team.
You now, by virtue of being here
and being in this conference
and going to the
various sessions,
have access to very
powerful technology
that's much easier to use
and much easier to operate.
And so that's what we are
going to discuss today.
Let's start with a few
other applications.
Image one is a very
nice one to start
with because it's very visual.
There's many other ways that
data is used productively.
The way I like to think
about it is to break it down
in two categories.
There is a set of
use cases where
data is used to inform humans.
A human has to make a decision.
It would be nice if
that decision was
informed by real event data.
And so that's a more
traditional model of analytics,
business intelligence.
And that's still very
important, obviously.
And so some examples here where
you can get much more complete
insight into your supply chain,
much more timely insight,
as well.
So if one part of your
supply chain, one partner,
is causing issues,
you want to be
able to know that for
sure, as opposed to having
an intuition that that
partner, really, you get
lots of complaints about them.
And getting that insight
quickly when you can act on it.
Another example of
use case, well, I'm
a product manager so I make
product decisions quite often.
It's nice when you can
make those decisions based
on actual data, as
opposed to insight.
We all think we
have great intuition
and we all fool ourselves
when we think that.
And so data can be used
to better understand
user behavior, to run
experiments, launch
a feature or a version of
a feature to a set of users
and really compare how
that affects the behavior.
And so there's just a
few examples of cases
where data is used to inform
humans who make decisions.
And then, more and more,
there are cases where
the human is out of the loop.
Where the analysis of
the data is used directly
to affect the behavior
of your applications.
The most typical example
that we see all the time
is when you go
shopping, depending
on what you've bought, what
you purchase, recommendations,
that's well understood.
And there's no human, obviously,
making those recommendations.
But it goes way beyond.
There are many
systems where you just
wouldn't have the time for
a human, anyway, to react.
When you're looking at financial
transactions happening very
quickly, and time is money.
Fraud has to be
stopped right away.
It just wouldn't
be possible anyway,
even if you had armies of
humans to do it manually.
And that's where you want the
machine to act automatically
or to resolve issues
and automate processes.
These are some of the examples.
Obviously, to make
them happen, you
need to actually
have access to data.
And people sometimes
wonder, well,
do I really have access
to the kind of data?
I don't have cars going
all around the world taking
pictures.
I don't have that kind of data
which has powerful insights.
And in reality, if
you take a step back
and think about
your data, you need
to think much more broadly.
Obviously, there is the
data that you already
analyzed today.
And that one, you usually
know it quite well
and have a good sense
of the value that
can be extracted from it.
But then, there is a lot
of data that you collect
but don't really analyze.
Maybe you collected because that
was the default configuration,
to collect all that data.
Or you collected
because some people
want to be able, occasionally,
to go do a point lookup
and find out what happened
that day at that time.
Well, let me go in the
log and figure it out.
But there is really no
rigorous, holistic use
of the data in that context.
And so that data really is
directly available for more
advanced processing.
And then there's a lot of
data that you could collect
but don't, because if you don't
have a plan to do something
with it, why would you bother?
Why would you collect it?
But as you get access
to the technology,
as that technology
becomes easy to use,
it really makes sense to
start thinking more around,
well, maybe I could
instrument this.
Maybe I could collect
that data and bring it.
And then the fourth
category is data
that you don't necessarily
create and generate,
but that you could get
access to by asking somebody.
And so one example would be
data from commercial providers
or other third parties
that you could either have
an arrangement with or purchase,
or data from your partners
who would be
willing to integrate
more closely with you.
So I would encourage you
to think a lot more broadly
about data that's
available on the platform.
One of the things we announced
this morning in the keynote
is that we now have BigQuery
transfer service, which
is going to automate
bringing your marketing
data at Google from AdWord,
from DoubleClick, from YouTube,
if you're a publisher,
directly into Cloud.
We also work with commercial
dataset providers,
like Dow Jones, to make
data available directly.
So there's really a big universe
of data available to you.
Now on the downside,
historically, it's
been hard to use
data, which is why
many people haven't done it.
Or those who've done it,
installed Hadoop Cluster
and tried to get
some value there
have often found
that pretty painful.
And one of the points
that has made that painful
is that you had to--
that data rarely comes
in a way that's ready to
use and ready to process.
You have to prepare it,
you have to clean it,
you have to get it
in the right shape,
and that's been challenging.
And so one thing
that we introduced
this morning is a new
service on Google Cloud
called Google Cloud Dataprep,
specifically to address that.
And to address
that in a way which
does not require writing
code and having access
to developers.
So it's empowering the end
users of the data, those
who understand the model,
those who understand
the content of the data, to
help themselves and prepare it
for analysis.
And so rather than waving
my hands and describing it,
I'm going to do that via
an example and a demo.
Let me set the example.
The use case here is
you are a retailer
and you have transaction data.
So every time somebody
does a purchase,
that's a new row
on that transaction
table at the top, which
contains, among other things,
all the products
that were purchased.
And so you get one row.
If you buy five products,
it's one transaction, one row.
And then, within that
row, you see that there
is that array of JSON objects.
And so each product
purchased was one JSON object
about that product
altogether in that array.
So that's nice.
You have all your data.
But here, what we're
going to try to do
is to map that product purchase
to an ad impression that
may have influenced it.
And so the second dataset
is ad impressions.
What ad, about what product,
had been displayed to what user?
So what we're going
to try to do here
is simply let me see what are
the instances where a given
customer purchased
a given product
after that same customer
has been shown an ad
for that product?
It's not rocket science.
It's something any
business person
should be able to express.
But in practice, when
your data looks like that,
there is quite a bit of work
to be able to extract that.
Because in my retail
data site, the product ID
is buried within all
the product purchased
in that one transaction.
And then in the
advertising that dataset,
the product ID is a
parameter in the URL.
So normally, I would have
to write quite a bit of code
to go and extradite data and
do all the cleaning needed.
And so if we can switch
to the demo screen,
we are now going to show how
to do that in Google Cloud Data
Prep.
Can I have the demo
laptop on, please?
OK.
We're on?
Yes.
This is the empty UI.
Nothing has been loaded.
The first thing that we're
going to do is create a flow.
A flow is really an
organizational envelope
for a set of work you're
trying to purchase.
So we're going to
create this new flow.
And the first thing we do
is to add datasets to it.
These are the two
datasets I mentioned.
This is a CSV file in
Google Cloud Storage.
These are my ad impressions.
And this one is
a BigQuery table,
which contains my
retail transactions.
So I just have to add them.
And then the tool will
automatically load these two.
In the case of the
BigQuery table,
it can show me a
preview of that table.
The CSV file, well, it's just a
text file so it's pretty messy.
But already the tool
infers some transformation
to break it down
by row, by column,
and to discover that
the first row contains
the name of the headers.
And so already,
there is a recipe
that has been auto-created with
some simple transformation.
Now let's make use of that.
We're going to start
with the BigQuery table
and we're going to
add a new recipe.
And so a recipe is the way
that [? data ?] prep works.
In effect, what you do when
you work with the tool is
you create recipes
that capture the way
you want to prepare the data.
Here's the interface where
you spend most of your time.
What it lets you do is interact
with your data directly.
It's not a tool when you have to
think about the transformation
you want to apply and then
drag and drop components that
represent that transformation.
No, you think starting
from the data, as opposed
to from the transformation.
And so in this
case, you recognize
what I was showing on
the slide of that--
let me just expand the
column a little bit.
That array of JSON object,
which is pretty messy.
If I expand one of them,
there's quite a lot there.
And so to try to make sense
of this, all I have to do
is click on that column.
And that's really the
principle of the tool.
In practice, the way it works
is you click on the data
that you're interested
in and you indicate,
via those clicks, what
you're trying to get done.
And then at the
bottom, you can see
the tool suggests a
potential transformation that
would make sense for that data.
In this case, I see there's
one suggestion here, which
is convert this
one row which has
an array into a set of rows.
And so each item in the
array becomes its own row.
And so if I look at
what this one would do,
if I go into preview--
right now I'm in
the preview and it
shows me that-- let me
just close this here.
It shows me that
now, you see where
I used to have an
array of JSON objects,
now I have one JSON object.
Because what used to be
one row per transaction
is now one row per product
purchased in the transaction.
So if I bought five
products, I now
have five individual rows, which
is more convenient because I'm
looking for a specific product.
And so I like that and I'm
going to add to recipe.
And so now, here are my rows
already there in the recipe.
The next thing I
want to do is I want
to go inside that JSON object
and extract, specifically,
the product key.
Now, there are many
ways to do that.
Because again, the tool is going
to try to guess and help me.
For example, I can
click on the column
again and then look
at a suggestion.
The first suggestion is to
create one column per variable
in JSON.
So I have 13 variables,
[? cells, ?] [INAUDIBLE],
line key item, product key.
I could just say,
expand that and create
13 different columns.
And that would be a
good way to do it.
In this case, I actually only
care about the product key.
So another way I could do that
is I can just go and highlight
Product Key and that's my hint.
And then the tool is
going to think about that.
And then the
suggestion is, do you
want to create a new column
using that product key
variable?
And that sounds good to me.
The preview looks like
what I want to do.
I want to extract
that product key.
And so all I do is
add that to recipe.
If I can close that
little preview here.
And then-- sorry, wrong click.
Here I have that new column that
extracts the product key, now
easily available without
having to write any code.
Let's switch to my other
dataset, the advertising
dataset.
Remember, that's a CSV file.
And already, as
I showed earlier,
the tool has created some steps
in the recipe to break down
or to use the new line
as a row separator,
to recognize the column
separator, and the header.
And those steps sound good,
so I'm going to keep them.
If I look at the histogram
of the data for every column,
I notice that, for
the event time, which
is when the ad was displayed,
there is some red here.
And the red represents
mismatched values.
And so again, I
just click on that.
And then the tool asks
me, what do you want?
Do you want to only
keep those values
or do you want to
delete those values?
And in this case,
obviously, what
makes sense here is to delete
the values because this is not
useful to me.
And so I just select that
choice, add to recipe.
And now we can see that those
mismatched values are filtered
out and I can keep working on.
Let's keep looking
at the histograms.
For User ID, for
example, there's
a pretty smooth histogram
here between various user IDs,
except that one
is very prevalent.
So I click on it and then,
again, the tool suggests,
do you want to
just keep that one?
Do you just want
to delete that one?
Well, at this point, I don't
really know which I want to do.
But let's say I just
want to keep it.
Just show me the rows that I
would be keeping if I-- sorry.
I keep the-- no, sorry, User ID.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm just keeping that user ID.
And then, the thing
that's interesting
now is I see the event
time for that user.
And there's basically a
click every second here.
And so that's why that user
is so predominant in my logs,
is that probably
it's a robot that's
just clicking every second.
So I'm not going to keep it.
I'm doing the opposite.
I'm going to delete that user.
So now it shows me,
in the red, those rows
are going to be removed.
Yes, I like that.
I add this to the recipe.
OK.
We've done some cleanup
removing invalid time values,
removing suspicious users.
Let's go back to the
original goal, which
is to extract the product ID.
And as you remember, this is the
URL for the ad and the product
ID is embedded there.
So really, all I have to do is
to click to expand one of them
and just give the tool a hint,
like I'm looking for this.
And so first hint.
And the tool thinks,
oh, are you looking
for that specific value?
Well, no.
I'm looking for a pattern here.
So let me give it
the second hint.
I'm going to close this one.
Well, it's not just this one.
Let me open another
one and let me select
that pattern on another one.
Now, it's like, oh, OK.
I get it.
You're not looking
for that value.
You're looking for that pattern.
And it's making suggestions
as in where I would want
to be looking for that pattern.
And so here, for
example, it's digit
followed by dash
followed by digits
starting after the equals sign.
OK.
That's a good pattern.
Actually, I'm going to make it
more robust because there could
be other-- have more variables.
There could be other
equal signs in my URL.
So I'm going to
modify the recipe.
And instead of
starting after equal,
I'm going to have it
start after PID equal.
This way, I'll be more
robust if there is
more patterns, more variables.
Add that to the recipe.
Here it is.
It created this
new column, URL1.
It just adds a 1 to
the original one,
which contains those product
IDs that have been extracted.
Let's rename it to something
a bit more useful than URL1.
This is the product ID.
And then the renaming, that's
another step in the recipe.
And you don't have to worry
about optimizing the steps
and doing the filtering
before the renaming.
All that will be optimized
automatically for you.
So don't worry about that.
Just express what
you want to get done.
And now, we have
those two datasets.
We've cleaned them.
We've extracted the product ID.
Now we can join between them.
And so let's do that
directly in the tool.
There's a join
that you can apply.
Actually, let me-- yes.
Now it's asking me,
again, what I want
to join that current dataset.
So I'm going to join it against
the retail dataset, which
I've prepared.
Select the preview.
Let's pick the join keys.
It's going to look at my data
and try to infer the join key.
And what it suggests is to
join product ID from the ads
to product key from the
transaction, and that's one.
That's a good one.
I like that one.
But remember, I'm trying to
look for a purchase of a product
by a given user if
that same user has
seen the ad for that product.
So I also have to add an
additional set of join keys
to do on the user.
And so it's suggesting
to join the user ID.
OK.
That sounds good.
But user ID with product
key, I do not want this.
So I can edit.
And what I'm going to join
with is the customer key.
Here, we have two pairs of keys.
Product ID to product key,
user ID to customer key.
That's what I want.
I can select which
columns I want to keep
in the result of my join.
Here, I want to compare the
time difference between the two.
I want to pick the event time
and I want to pick the order--
where is the order?
Order date, there it is.
And I can pick any
other I want, obviously.
And then add that
join to the recipe.
And here I am, back
in the data center QI
to show me the result of
that join across those keys
and with the time.
In many cases, maybe that's the
kind of cleaning I want to do.
I'm done here.
I don't have to do the
difference between the two
times because I will do that
later in my visualization tool.
Or maybe I want to do it here.
Maybe I want to add some more.
And so I can select
the event time.
And then I select--
where's the other one?
The order time.
What happened to the order time?
There it is, the order date.
Now, if I select those
two, what the tool suggests
me is to create a new column.
Yes.
Except I want the
time difference.
There it is.
Here, the tool suggests
to create a new column
where the value is the time
difference between those two
[? dead ?] columns.
I like that, except seconds
is probably too granular,
so I'm going to modify.
And instead of
seconds, I'm going
to do it expressed in minutes.
Add that to recipe.
And oops, sorry.
Wrong click again.
There we go.
We have that new column created.
That content is the
result of the calculation.
Let's rename it
something more useful.
We're going to call
it time difference.
Add to recipe.
Again, here-- that's about it.
[INAUDIBLE] Did I click
in the wrong place?
Oh, here it is.
It was already added
so clicked it twice.
I have now that
new column that's
added to do the time difference.
As you can see, without
writing a line of code,
just by interacting
with my data,
I'm pointing at things I
want to do, choosing columns
I want to use together, I was
able to describe that pipeline
which I can then execute.
And we'll talk about Dataflow,
the underlying service.
But the thing to
know in that context
is that your job is done.
The execution is, at that
point, fully automated.
You just have to run the job.
There is nothing to
deploy, nothing to manage.
Even if your retail transaction
is terabytes and terabytes
in size, it's going to
run in Google Cloud,
execute, and deliver to you the
result of that transformation.
Let's go back to the
slides now, please.
That was a demo of how,
without writing code,
you can do a lot of very
typical, common, and useful
transformational steps.
Now, there are cases where
this is not the right tool.
There are a lot
of more advanced,
with pretty complex
processing algorithms,
with branching logic, where,
really, code is the right way
to express your transformation.
Maybe you want to run
a streaming pipeline.
In that case, you
want to write code
because code is the best
way to express that.
But you still want to
do that in a way that's
friendly and productive.
And historically, that
hasn't been the case.
Historically, a lot of
large scale data processing,
the tools available
have been designed
for the convenience
of infrastructure
and not of the user.
Take MapReduce, for example.
MapReduce is awesome.
Google was built on MapReduce.
But really, MapReduce
forces a developer
to learn a new way of thinking.
And especially if they have
a more complex pipeline
they have to optimize.
It's actually a lot of work to
write really good MapReduce.
But it's very easy
then, once you've
done it in MapReduce,
for the infrastructure
to paralyze your work.
So that was the trade-off.
But that has limited access
to be big data to a much
smaller subset of developers.
And that really doesn't
have to be anymore.
Same thing with batch.
For some reason,
as an industry, we
tend to assume that there's
something natural about batch.
That, of course, things
at scale happen in batch.
And in reality, there's really
nothing intuitive about that.
It's just the force of habit
that makes us think about that.
The world doesn't work in batch.
Things happen continuously.
And so the tools have been
forcing us to think in batch
mode when, really, we shouldn't.
Also, they've been forcing
us to think about events,
in terms of when they're
processed, when they arrive
in your pricing
logic, as opposed
to when they actually happened,
which is not always the same.
And so the reason
why, right now, there
is a lot more easy
access to big data
is because those
constraints have really
been removed by a much more
mature programming model.
And Reza is going to
tell us about that.
REZA ROKNI: Thank you very much.
The last couple
of years, I think
I've been very, very lucky
in that I've actually worked
directly with our customers
doing a little bit of that code
stuff to actually convert
batch processing pipelines over
to streaming.
And actually, before we
talk about Dataflow itself,
let's think about how we're
going to collect this data.
Let's just take two simple
examples of stream data.
One is IoT data.
Imagine there's lots of
factories that we have.
There is IoT devices
measuring temperature,
measuring the number of
machines that are on.
All of these devices are sending
information to somewhere.
And the other use case
that I commonly come across
is click stream.
As users are clicking around
your applications on a website,
they're doing stuff on their
mobile, all of these events
are click stream information
that's being recorded and being
processed.
Normally, obviously,
that usually
gets processed by
batch processing,
but as we move to
stream processing,
we now need a way
of capturing that.
And Google Cloud Pub/Sub API
is a publish and subscribe API.
There's no running up machines.
It's fully managed service.
Essentially, it's the
easiest part of any POC
that I do with customers.
It's four or five clicks.
I get a topic created.
And what that allows you to do
is, from anywhere in the globe,
you can send information to it.
We can process it in
any region that we like.
It is highly
available and it means
when a message is recorded
and acknowledged by Pub/Sub,
it will actually keep it in the
system for up to seven days,
or until the subscription
pulls that message
and acknowledges that
it's being processed.
This piece usually
takes a few minutes
to set up in any POC and it
will deal with several messages
a second or, as with
some of my customers,
hundreds of thousands
of messages per second.
Going on to Dataflow
itself, historically,
it's been considered that if
you wanted accurate processing,
you tended to need a
batch processing pipeline.
So you would have
batch technology,
you would collect all the
files at the end of the day,
maybe do some
corrections, some ETL,
and then do some batch
processing on it.
If you wanted low latency,
you would then go and build
a completely separate
technology stack
that would absorb
the streams of data
and do some processing for real
time dashboards, et cetera.
But it was always
considered that that was not
accurate enough for something
like a billing pipeline.
Now, why is streaming difficult?
Well, let's take that simple
example of click stream.
Now, one of the common
problems of streaming pipelines
is late data.
Imagine one of your
applications is a mobile device.
Your users are going to be
going in and out of cell range,
they're going to
lose connectivity.
They're still using,
potentially, the application.
As it's recording information,
when it suddenly comes back
online, its going to
send a clump of data.
Now, if one of the
things that we want to do
is accurately count
how many people
are on our applications
any point in that day,
at this point,
we've got a problem
because we're going to miscount.
Now, what Dataflow
allows us to do
is it gives us a powerful
programming model that
is geared towards streaming.
It can deal with batch, as well.
But what it allows
you to do is deal
with things like late data.
It gives you simple
primitives to deal
with things like windowing
and sessionization.
And the Dataflow
programming model in SDK
was contributed to Apache Beam.
It's now an open source project.
And Apache Beam, there
are several folks
building runners for it.
So we have Spark and also
other execution engines
like Flink and Apex who
are building runners.
Now very quickly,
I'm going to show
a demo of a Dataflow running.
So if we can move over
to the laptop, please.
Thank you very much.
Right now, we're connecting to
the monitoring UI of Dataflow.
And the example
that's working here,
for anyone who was at
the session yesterday,
this is an IoT example.
There is messages
coming from a factory.
They have got temperature,
et cetera, encoded in them.
What we're doing is we're
absorbing that through Pub/Sub
and Dataflow is
pulling from Pub/Sub.
It's reading the
IoT device data.
We are parsing the message.
We're pulling out little
bits of information
from the JSON
package that's there.
And then, I'm actually
doing three different types
of processing with that data.
The first one, and I consider
this, best practice always,
is before any processing,
I want all the raw data
to be dumped into a repository.
And at this point, we're
putting it into BigQuery
because then we can run
SQL analysis against it.
We'll come back to
BigQuery in a moment.
And on the other side, we are
doing some basic processing
against the data.
So here, I'm creating a
simple sliding window.
That's two lines of code.
Then I'm doing a
mean calculation,
so within the last five minutes,
what was the temperature?
Then I'm doing a very
simplistic check.
If the temperature was over
x, send the message back
into Pub/Sub.
So here, Pub/Sub is not only
being used as the ingestion
mechanism into Dataflow,
it's being used as the glue
to connect systems together.
So I'm sending a message
saying AC on or off.
And then the factory
can pick that up.
More interestingly,
down this middle path--
that was a simple, is the
temperature over 30 degrees?
But down this middle
path, we actually
called the cloud machine
learning service.
Here, we have
built a model based
on data that would
have been previously
recorded in BigQuery,
all that raw data
that we should have recorded.
It is able to then tell us
what the optimum time to turn
the fans on.
Here, instead of making
that simple check,
I make a rest call to the
inference service on the model.
It will tell me whether the
fan should come on based
on the heuristics that we--
based on the cost optimization
that we had in mind,
which is efficiency.
And it will then, again,
we put it back into Pub/Sub
to push back into our factories.
We're talking heavily
about retail use case
here with the sales data
that William went through
on Data Prep.
A simple example
for retail would
be take those IT
temperature readings
and imagine they're
actually coming from stores.
And what we're trying to
do is, what temperature
should the store
be set at to make
sure people are spending lots
of good money in your stores?
OK.
Back to William.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Can we go
back to the slides, please?
We talked about the difficulty
of writing pipelines
and how you can
now, in many cases,
not even have to write any code.
Or if you do have
to write some code,
have a very powerful and
convenient programming model,
like Beam, running on
Dataflow, which Reza showed.
That really is only
the tip of the iceberg,
though, in terms of
complexity usually faced,
in terms of running big
data in an organization.
Quite often, the hard part that
comes after that is, how do you
operationalize that?
OK.
You've written your
first pipeline.
How do you make sure
it runs at scale
with just the right
amount of infrastructure?
And that's often
pretty complicated.
And there are two
main aspects there.
One is the human aspect.
It is a lot of work
for people to have
to deal with
provisioning and patching
and reliability and security
and performance and optimization
and all those
operational aspects which
you have to deal with.
Because by definition, big data
runs on a significant amount
of computing power.
So you have to manage
it efficiently.
Otherwise, you are
spending way too much.
It's just not doable.
And so in reality,
this is where you
want to spend your time,
bringing your business
expertise to the data and
not doing all the operations
and trying to guess how much
capacity you're going to need.
So there's a human workload
aspect and skill set
set of constraints here.
In addition to that,
there is just resources.
How often have
you found yourself
feeling like you have a tiny
shovel and a really big job?
And you're not getting
the resources you need.
But that's because
it's really hard
to get large amount
of resources,
at least until you
know for sure what
you are trying to get done.
And the important thing
is that you really
want to encourage
people to try things,
to iterate, to fail quickly,
to move on to the next thing.
But if they cannot get
infrastructure to support this
experimentation, they're
going to do toy projects.
And the solution here is
what the industry now called
serverless, which is an approach
to data processing that takes
care of and automates all
of the management [? NME ?]
[? session ?] processes and
allows you to focus on writing
the job.
So insight, business
expertise, no administration.
It also means that you get
access to a lot of resources
when you need them.
But you only pay exactly
for what you use.
And so if you have an
idea in the morning,
you can start and analyze
large amounts of data
to really validate your idea.
And if it doesn't work, you've
wasted an hour and $5.00 worth
of processing.
If, on the other
hand, it does work,
well, you don't
have a toy project
that you have to throw away
and reimplement at large scale.
You have something which
is built on services that
can natively scale to any size.
And so any experiment
that is successful
is ready to operationalize
and productize right away.
And that's really-- the
most important part is that.
It's not the technology.
It's really the way teams
learn to work and test
ideas and iterate
very, very quickly,
as opposed to any new idea
being yet another IT project.
In practice, when I
talk about serverless,
well, there's many
services on the platform.
But the three that I would call
out as the most obvious example
have the nice characteristic
that they cover the three
main stages of data lifecycle.
Reza talked about Pub/Sub
for event ingestion.
Nothing to manage,
just [? query ?] topic
and pump as many
events as you want.
And only pay based on how
much data you put through.
Don't have to guess and
pre-provision ahead of time.
Dataflow, as well.
Reza described the quality
of the programming model.
But the thing that's really
unique about Dataflow
as a [? Beam ?] runner is
it's a serverless system where
you don't deploy the cluster.
You submit a job and then
the job automatically
gets the resources
it needs, autoscale.
So whether you use Dataprep to
create that job or you write
it yourself, once you've created
the pipeline, you're done.
Everything else is automated.
And then the third one, which
we are talking about now,
is BigQuery for SQL analytics.
Again, serverless
and at any scale.
And so Reza, please,
tell us about BigQuery.
REZA ROKNI: Can we go back
to the laptop, please?
Thank you.
What we have here is the
BigQuery user interface.
I'm actually going
to run a query which
is a little bit unusual.
I'm going to run a query
of one petabyte of data.
The table in question
is a retail dataset
with a table sales partition.
I can actually see
the schema here.
If I go to details,
we see that it is just
over a petabyte
of data in volume
and around a trillion rows,
well, just over trillion rows
to compute.
Now, BigQuery is a
[? columnar ?] [? iOS ?]
storage format, so we don't--
and actually, it's been
moved to a capacitor
since its first inception.
But here, I'm just going to
do is select Start, which
is a bit of an unusual
thing to do here, and look
for a single predicate.
This is just to
force it to compute
against the whole dataset.
So I'm going to kick that
off and get it to run.
That will take a few
minutes to actually-- sorry,
that's being cached.
Let me remove the cache.
So BigQuery will cache results
if you've run it before.
Obviously, we don't
want to do that.
Let's get it running properly.
That's now going to run.
It's going to take
a few minutes.
If we can go back to
the slides, please.
Let's think about
what actually is
a petabyte I'm going to
show my age a little bit
here and talk
about floppy disks.
If you wanted to
store floppy disks,
a petabyte onto floppy disks,
you'd have to stack up 12
Empire State buildings'
worth of them.
It would take you 27
years to download over 4G.
And it's every tweet
ever made times 50.
But that's a big number,
obviously, a petabyte.
But it can also
be a small number.
So It's the data that's encoded
in just two micrograms of DNA.
It's one day's worth
of YouTube video.
It's 200 servers logging,
at a fair pace, admittedly,
50 entries a second
for three years.
So there's going to be
more and more datasets that
actually have these
kind of volumes of data
as we move forward.
And where did
BigQuery come from?
BigQuery's based on a
technology called Dremel.
And in 2002, Google had
more and more data to store
and the Google File
System was bought.
It allowed you to store all of
this data on commodity servers.
Fantastic.
We solved the problem of
how to store lots of data.
By 2004, we had
lots of data and we
had to figure out the
problem of, how do
you process all of that data?
So Jeff Dean and co.,
MapReduce was used
and it was very heavily
used to actually
be able to process all
of the data that we had.
Now, when you're
doing analytics,
you don't just write the
perfect query at the end.
You wake up in the
morning and you've
got it all ready for you.
You will look at your data,
you want to analyze it.
If you're doing a
MapReduce, you'd
have to do some analysis
with the first MapReduce.
Then you would take the
result set, look at that,
do another MapReduce.
And so our engineers got bored
with going out for coffee
every time they ran
that first MapReduce
and building all the plumbing
in between the stuff.
And they wrote Dremel.
And Dremel allows
you to run queries
against petabytes of data, as
we're doing in the demo now.
And it's the same
technology that has
been externalized as BigQuery.
So it's the same code base, it's
the same SREs and engineers.
And within Google today,
Dremel is the core
of our ad hoc analytics.
And with their
warehousing needs,
most Googlers will touch
it, myself and William
will touch it more directly,
things with Dremel.
However, other people will be
using it through dashboards.
OK.
This query is still running.
For now, we're going to
switch back to William.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Can we go
back to the slides, please?
You talk too fast.
REZA ROKNI: I do, sorry.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Speaking of the data
and the way it's being
stored and queried
in Dremel at Google,
at Google have
lots of different
storage systems
and lots of different
processing systems.
You want to go back to
the slide for a second?
REZA ROKNI: Sorry.
Yeah.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Go back
to the demo for a second.
REZA ROKNI: I just needed
to slow down for 20 seconds
and it would have been fine.
If we go back, that
query completed.
It processed a petabyte of data.
Took 161 seconds to complete.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: That's
two minutes and 40 seconds.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
REZA ROKNI: Back to
the slides, please.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Back to the slides.
One of the other issues that's
been preventing or making
it harder to access
and analyze data scale
is the siloed
nature of the data.
The fact that, quite often,
data is within a tool.
And if you want to use
another tool to process it,
well, then you have to
extract it, move it, copy it,
have different versions.
And at Google, we
have lots of ways
to store data and lots of
ways to process data and lots
of data between the two.
And if we had to do
that, that would just
explode the data centers.
And so one fundamental
principle is that any tool
can access data in any storage.
And that's really,
really important,
in terms of allowing a much
broader analysis across sources
of datasets.
And so in Cloud, the way
that [? matterizes ?]
itself is with something like
Dataflow, which Reza described.
Being able to access data
in Google Cloud storage,
in BigQuery, in BigTable--
that's our NoSQL service--
in data store, all the
databases that we have.
In Pub/Sub for event stream.
Wherever data is, Dataflow
can get it and process it.
Now, it's maybe less
intuitive, but the same thing
is true for BigQuery, as well.
If you're going to try to go
through a petabyte of data
in-- what was it?
Two minutes and 40 seconds?--
you have to put the
data in BigQuery storage
because it's a highly optimized
storage system for analytics.
But in many cases, you don't
have petabytes of data.
It might be more convenient
to leave the data elsewhere
as a file in Google
Cloud Storage in BigTable
or maybe just even
in Google Drive.
So in my laptop, I can
have a CSV file, which I
drag in my Google Drive folder.
It gets synchronized
to Google Drive
and now I can write
a BigQuery query that
is going to join from that
CSV file in Google Drive,
with a log table in BigQuery.
And so BigQuery has
that functionality
to bring SQL analytics to
all the structured data
on the Cloud.
And then finally,
another product
we haven't talked about yet
is Dataproc for [? managed ?]
Spark and Hadoop.
What it allows you to do is to
bring the power and richness
of the Hadoop ecosystem
and Spark ecosystem
to Google Cloud.
Because the key thing you use
the right tool for the job.
And if the right tool is a Spark
library that somebody wrote,
then you should be
able to use that.
And Dataproc will give you
a fully configured cluster
in about 90 seconds.
And that cluster will
have direct access
to data, again, in the
storage system, such
that the first thing you do is
not load the data in Hadoop.
The first thing you
do is run the job.
So you can start a
job, run, shut down
your cluster when you're done,
and you pay by the minute.
And so it's standard
Hadoop and Spark,
but it enables them to run in
a very dynamic, efficient Cloud
native way.
And again, accessing
your data wherever it is.
And then finally, the last set
of issues that people typically
run into is just
the tooling to do
something useful with the data.
Because at the end,
it's nice to be
able to collect it and
process it, but to what end?
And going back to the use
cases, quite often, that end
is to inform a human.
So there are tools
that help you do that.
On the platform,
specifically, there
are two main tools which
are directly accessible.
One is Datalab.
Datalab is targeted
at data scientists.
And so for data scientists,
Jupiter notebooks
are a very popular
way to analyze data.
And what Datalab is is Jupiter
closely integrated with Google
Cloud platform to
allow data scientists
to benefit from all the
Jupiter modules and experience,
but do that in a way that
enables collaboration
and usage on the platform.
And Reza is going to
show that in action.
REZA ROKNI: Yeah.
The interesting
thing about notebooks
is it's the data
scientists' scratchpad.
As they're going through
and analyzing the data,
they can just record
their results.
They can go back to them.
They can use that,
even, as something
that you pass to the
data engineers, which
would be me, to actually
go and put into production.
And the other thing--
the great way that
I've seen them
used is, at the end
of their conclusions,
after they've come to what they
think is the right way forward,
they'll present the notebook
back to their colleagues.
And that's great
because at the end, when
they have that final
result, you might
have a question like, why did
you use column A not column B?
And they'll go
back and say, well,
actually, I looked at column A
and I saw a skew in the data.
Therefore, I
switched to column B.
And it's a great way to actually
maintain all of the knowledge
that you gain as you
explore your dataset.
If we could switch to
the laptop, please.
What we have here
is a Datalab that's
been set up to run in Dataproc.
I'll manage Hadoop and Spark.
And what I'm going
to do is actually use
the Datalab in
conjunction with BigQuery,
in conjunction with
Spark to actually do
some simple analysis
against that sales data.
What I want to do is--
as you can see, it is a
hands-on, technical tool.
What I'm going to do is look
at the sales information
and the first question
I'm going to say is,
OK, let's figure out
how many items there
are in an average basket.
I would write a bit
of SQL, run that sell.
I would then call the
BigQuery connector.
It's gone and actually
used the power of BigQuery
to do the hard computation.
It's given me back a
table with eight rows.
Now, the eight rows
weren't sorted.
OK.
So I could go and rewrite
the query with an order by.
But actually, as
I'm in the notebook,
I'll just use the sort
from the data frame.
Great.
I can actually see now
that, in general, there
are between 8 and 11 seems to
be the average number of items
that we're going to
have in our basket.
OK.
Interesting.
Let's start doing a
plot, my favorite tool.
Great.
We got a visual
representation of that data.
Let's move on to something
a little bit more tricky.
What I want to do
now is figure out,
what are the things
that are actually
bought with each other?
That would be incredibly
difficult to do with something
like SQL because you need to get
the power set of all the items
together.
What I'm going to do is make a
combination usage of BigQuery
plus some MLlib library
algorithms that exist in Spark.
I'm going to get the
data ready in BigQuery.
So what I'm doing
here is generating
a set of data for this demo.
I'm just limiting it to
1,000 rows to return.
And if we look at
that head, what that's
done is gone through
all of my sales data
and just concatenated
all of the product IDs,
the same product IDs you
were seeing when William
was running the Data Prep demo.
It's put them all onto
a transaction line.
This is now perfectly
ready for my algorithm.
So I'm not going to do any work
in Spark to get the data ready.
Now I'm going to get
this put into an IDD.
OK.
Those are the thousand
datasets that are there.
Next step, I'm going to
run the algorithm, which
is this FB Grow from Spark.
Look at the results.
It gave me 36 results.
I'm going to look at what
are items bigger than two?
I won't go into the
details of that.
OK.
As I mentioned before,
BigQuery does cache results.
This morning I had
run the limit 1,000,
so I don't have to
do some typing here.
The first thing I would do
after getting some results
back is go and check them.
What I'm doing here is I'm
going to use those product IDs,
go back to my dataset, and
see, what is it that people
buy together based off category?
So this is building
materials and outdoors.
OK.
Interesting.
At this point, we now
have most of everything
that's ready to pass
to a data engineer.
They can then go on
productionize this
and churn out the information
across the whole dataset
to start figuring out, what are
the items we should recommend
on our website?
OK?
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: OK.
Back to the slides, please.
Thank you, Reza.
This was Datalab for scientists.
Since this is an
intro session, I
don't expect many people into
this room are data scientists.
But people in your
organizations or people
you might work with who
have that skill, that
is the tool that would be
most familiar with them
and allow them to
collaborate with you
on the same data in Google
using the tools they want.
For more business
analyst type of people,
line of business
managers, people
who are more on that side of
the business, one tool that's
on the platform
that's quite useful
is Data Studio for reports.
And that's another
serverless, in the sense that,
if you don't install
anything, either on the client
or on the server, it
works like Google Drive.
It is a collaborative
environment.
I expect many of you are
familiar with Google Drive,
and having presentation and
documents and spreadsheets.
And Data Studio
allows you to use
that exact same collaboration
model for creating and sharing
beautiful reports on
the platform directly.
Let's look at it in practice.
If we can switch back
to the laptop demo.
Do you have it?
Yeah.
This is an example of a
report, dashboard, in Datalab,
which has some calculated
value on the left side.
Remember, I mentioned
in the Dataprep demo,
once I've extracted
the time of the ad
and the time of the transaction,
I could do the calculation back
then in Data Prep or I
could leave those two
values nice and
clean and then do
the calculation in
Data Studio as part
of the creation of this report.
Either way would work.
I can look at my
various metrics here,
compared to target, et cetera.
All of those areas are being
controlled by that item
here, which was put there.
So instead of looking at
the last quarter of 2014,
I can go back and
look at the full year.
Here, I'm acting as a viewer of
the report, not as a creator.
And so anybody with whom
you've shared the report
would be able to do that
and adjust the report
to get to what they're
trying to get to.
So we just apply.
It gets recalculated, such
that the revenue is now
the full year
revenue, et cetera.
And so that's one
page of the dashboard.
There are other pages that
shows other kinds of views.
For example, here, having
this geographical view.
This one represents the profit
margin for various states.
You can hover over
the various states
and automatically, it
recognizes, in the data,
geographical information,
and offers visualization
specifically for
data that allow you
very easily, as a non-expert, to
put together those dashboards.
Can look at the
product demographics,
find out more about the
users, and what other database
on the customer tables
in the retail dataset.
Do some filtering on that,
so remove the male users,
for example, to filter down
to, let's say, all the female
except the baby boomers.
And then you can drill.
And automatically,
those selectors,
whether the dead selector or
those population characters
[? three ?] selectors, in the
case of this dashboard, where
we're configured to apply
to all of the visualization
on this page.
That's the experience as a user.
Someone has shared that with me.
I know nothing about
BigQuery or anything.
I just have that easy dashboard
that I can interact with
and I get inside for myself.
Now let's look at how
that dashboard actually
gets created.
And Reza, if you want
to show that in action.
REZA ROKNI: OK.
What I'm going to do now
is do a little bit of UI.
And there's a good
reason they usually
don't let me near any UIs,
as will soon become apparent.
I'm going to, first of
all, put this in Edit mode
and actually create a page.
So Create New Page.
At this point, I
have a blank page
to start building
out components on.
And what I'm going
to do is build out
one of those first graphs that
we had in that first page.
What I want to do
is a bar chart.
I'm going to put
the bar chart down.
And it's already
given me some options.
It's actually chosen
average age as a metric.
We want the revenue.
OK.
Revenue selected.
If I recollect, the style of
the graph on that first page
was horizontal, so let's
turn that horizontal.
There was also a
text bar at the top.
So let's just add that.
And my chart.
It was also gray and black line.
Let's put a weight around it.
OK.
And as I have very
little UX skills,
let's pick a color that I
think is very beautiful.
Gorgeous.
That looks beautiful.
I think I might need some help
from someone with a little bit
more UX skills.
So William, perhaps you could
come and join me in this.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Since that was
shared using the usual
model, now I get--
you see my icon here showing up
because I joined the dashboard.
And I can--
REZA ROKNI: There's
his beautiful picture.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: That's me.
And I can go and try and rescue
this chart from Reza's hands.
So before people start
leaving the room,
let me try and change
the color here.
REZA ROKNI: And this is my,
"look, no hands" moment.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Go to the start.
Basically, what I'm
seeing is the same thing
Reza was seeing when he was
doing the edit himself earlier.
Chart background, let's
make it a nice pink.
REZA ROKNI: How is that better?
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
It's less aggressive.
And then, how about like this?
How about that?
REZA ROKNI: OK.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: OK.
Now you can't read--
REZA ROKNI: I think we both
need to keep the day job, right?
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Anyway,
hopefully, you guys, we
haven't ruined your
appetite for the rest.
Let's do something
maybe more useful.
I'm going to add another chart.
Well, speaking of appetite,
let's do a pie chart.
There it is, showing up here.
By default, the data was
the product categories.
Here, I'll make it bigger.
Reza, you put yours
right in the middle.
You didn't give me any room.
By default here, we had
the product category.
Oh, thank you.
Then I can explain mine.
And then, instead of that,
I can put other dimension,
like the age of my users
or the gender of the users.
As I compose, the key thing
here is, for those of you
familiar with Drive
collaboration, that's
the usual experience, where
you see the other person
and you can,
together, collaborate.
Let's see.
Let's assume we've
reached perfection.
This is both
beautiful and useful.
Please show us how to share it.
REZA ROKNI: 50% correct.
We're going to
share this document.
If you use Google Drive, this
will be very familiar with you.
It's already shared,
that link is already
shared with my domain,
my company, google.com.
So anyone with that link
can access this dataset.
If I wanted to restrict
it further down,
I could choose emails
to limit who has access
to this particular dataset.
OK?
Back to William.
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE:
Thank you, Reza.
That's the typical Google
Drive sharing model.
So very useful collaboration.
If we can go back to
the slides, please.
Thank you.
And then another aspect here
that we want to finish on
is, as far as big data
processing, more and more, that
also includes machine learning.
And so we announced yesterday
that Machine Learning Engine
is now [? GA. ?] That's out
of scope for this session.
Plenty of machine
learning sessions here.
One set of APIs
which are actually
relevant to people who don't
have to be machine learning
experts is the fact
that you can use
APIs that expose models
that Google itself
has trained using our own data.
There's the Vision API to
extract insight from images.
What's in the image?
Recognize location, landmarks,
and a lot of things like that.
Speech API to automatically
transcribe voice into text.
Jobs API, that's a
pretty specialized API.
But I think that that's
where the industry is going.
In this case, having
an API specifically
for matching candidates'
resumes to job opportunity.
And something that goes way
beyond typical keyword matching
and really has been trained on
really, really large amounts
of data and has much
more insight about what
actually makes
sense for matching.
Recently, I was looking for a--
there was somebody who
passed me a candidate who
has Apache experience.
And I mean Apache's foundation.
And he actually had worked
on Apache helicopters.
Thank you.
That's not exactly
what I was looking at.
So that's the kind of--
you can go beyond word matching
and people who are quite
relevant for what you're doing.
Another one is Translation API.
I'm sure many of you have
used it as consumers.
It's available as an API
to use in your products
and in your data
pricing pipeline.
And finally, the Natural
Language API, which takes
text and tells you what
the text is talking about.
Which people, which
location, what's
the tone of the conversation?
Are people happy, unhappy?
And things like that.
That's an example of
something that anyone,
not a machine learning
expert, can start using.
In conclusion, I
think what we try
to do here is to do
a mix of explaining
the value of
serverless processing
and how it brings scale,
speed, and cost efficiency
to data processing.
But sure how the way to
use that, in many cases,
is via very easy tools.
And so we did a demo of Data
Prep for data preparation.
We did a demo of Data
Studio for data science--
sorry, Datalab for data science.
Data Studio for reports.
And how those give
you access to tools
like BigQuery that can process
petabytes, like Dataflow,
that can run pipelines and
batch and stream, et cetera.
Walking out of this, what
we would encourage you to do
is, of all the
products we've shown,
go and see the session
that drill deeper into some
of those.
Some of those sessions
actually happened yesterday,
but everything is going to be on
YouTube for you to catch up on.
And so whether it is--
Data Prep, there's a
session this afternoon
that is entirely about Data
Prep so you'll learn a bit more.
There's also a code
lab on the first floor
where you can get your
hands on it right away
and start playing with it.
So you can go there.
Or Data Flow, learn
how to use BigQuery.
All of those are here for
you today or on YouTube.
Thank you very much and
thanks for being here.
[APPLAUSE]